the new season won't premiere until
January but on Halloween
ABC dropped a quick little promo this
handsome man behind me Colton Underwood
the new bachelor this is the first time
we're seeing Colton officially as the
bachelor in his suit of course
surrounded by roses our very first look
a little Halloween present take a look
this Halloween no tricks just a treat
I'm your new bachelor
the new season of the boo chiller starts
this January on ABC well he is nailing
blowing those roses into the air and
that's one of the most important parts
of that job
but how will Colton be as the bachelor
what can we expect well even in the
downtime while the show is filming we
are constantly interviewing bachelor
stars and the father of the franchise
himself Chris Harrison here's what he
recently told us on a red carpet
Colton's going to be good TV and that is
the reason we chose him it's not an
indictment by the way on Blake on Jason
on anybody else it's just that at the
end of the day the the powers that be
decide Colton is going to be a good
story good TV he looks like The Bachelor
he probably won't have his shirt on
after night one so it's going to be a
good season Chris is right he does look
like The Bachelor the former football
player fills out a suit nicely in that
new promo why else will Colton make good
TV well Chris has told us look you can't
change the fact that he's the first
virgin ever show's history so that's
good TV in itself what will happen in
the fantasy suites we will see but
what's your former bachelors and one
breakout star think of Colton's chances
as a successful bachelor I spoke to Ben
Higgins Nick Viall and Dean anglers and
I heard radio in Las Vegas just a couple
weeks ago here's what they had to say
I think he'll do do fine I think we're
gonna see him struggle I think it's
gonna be a very authentic journey of
like struggling success failure a lot of
Tears I mean I was surprised by the
choice I mean I get why they picked him
it'll be interesting you know but you
know Colton by his own admission has
mentioned that he's got a very limited
dating life did the show eat you guys in
life yeah definitely destroyed me Wow
I've never been here to say one thing
and one thing only
Colton for bachelor not my bachelor Oh
Dean angler spittin some fire there Dean
also said but he wanted to say on the
record that he thinks that Colton is the
bachelor is a quote dumpster fire but he
will be watching it because of course
why wouldn't she watch a dumpster fire
you know what it's reality TV we love it
when it's good and we love it when it's
bad so the new season of The Bachelor
premieres in January
[Music]
[Applause]